all right welcome to some five-minute
action here I'll play one a 44 change
and we got an open Sicilian coming up
let's see what is playing rather give
earning and variation I'll play the
classical we should be too and see what
happens okay he decides to go for a set
up without a six it seems on Bishop e3
he's got this if I've move not quite
sure what what is the best again this
line and not usually for player
so what have I just retreat the night I
think this is quite uncommon but let's
try this okay he's immediately going for
the April advanced here I think he wants
to play on a4ai wats play night before
you preparing d5
you had this a five moves to disturb my
queen side but his weekend b5 and b6
himself so this is double-edged a bit
but not before would be normal here that
before then maybe Bishop d7 c6 and then
d 5 or a five-hour also an idea don't
think I'm maybe not at the moment he
five but first this night before Bishop
d7 kind of maneuver okay this is
something entirely different okay I'll
just continue development here but
certainly something which makes sense
not before it could be the point right
before I'd then d5 okay but I have still
some useful move that I can play over
protecting you for here a heart curious
why would you play rugby a young maybe
to protect the bishop on e5 right Mary
could have played Eve night before I
mean equal plenty five maybe but so what
would be useful here i would like to
like to prevent Bishop Knight to learn
before this would be nice maybe this one
putting some pressure on d6 and maybe
allowing c3 c3 and 92 to cover the
center aha so he wants to go to a six
hour okay so
if he wants to a 65 I think must be the
idea otherwise this move would make any
sense could go back because III is just
a move I want to play anyway so 9 a-6
that this have a drawback not sure yeah
well II 5s is interesting to open up the
position the fourth one is hanging out
song i play 92 he might play 95 and d5
right now I'll try this one ideas of the
white squared bishops the light square
Bishop CRI exchanged then this is 6
square gets very weak and I might have
this idea of 94 to to c6 yeah this was
also possible a team so just Bishop to
d2 maybe need to move this so yeah I
thought I could just take actually
shouldn't be too bad now let's complete
development here with look do you want
to come I have fun bit of an advantage
on the coincide with this knight on d5
position nice deep pressure on on d6
p.m. i roped you one maybe rook do you
want see for bishops III moves like this
could be quite good black storm seems to
be a fairly solid though like it's not
in you travel or something yeah the sun
is interesting okay just recapture
possible plenty hot so would be to to
plant the night on d6 if i get the dark
squared Bishop exchange this would be a
yeah quite good plan so what is this
exactly I can first you can take on b7
if I want I could exchange on c7c
certainly looks bad to exchange because
mobile phone would be quite a week
so let's grab here first then maybe look
or see form
yeah let's play see form this night is
still quite annoying and if he takes it
I'll get some nice play on the queenside
against the a porn he might can he might
be able to take and play Queen D for
what I just don't believe this move okay
so now my idea was Bishop c3n term rook
t1 okay might go worked his happen but
if I exchange by rookie 1 i'm just
quicker on the default so should i play
Queen to now 22 22 design money possibly
I can also click Rena three yeah let's
play queen of three the sir shouldn't be
too bad of exchanging the Queen's yeah
but I thought this moves might be a good
end game for me those pawns are so weak
I'll get a passed pawn immediately it
takes with the sea porn i have c 5 I
think this bonus is just promoting it
just has c7 to cross so to say and
difficult for him what how does he stop
the porn now so eyes got to check coming
I while it's still it's still very good
for me but
I hope I hope I'm not judging this
terribly timewise a some small of an
issue
kingi five coming up odessa prevent this
all right now you cannot detect the sea
porn with this king which is quite
helpful still not easy to see how to
make progress here oh no I I don't want
to take it really this looks like good
control maybe I need to do this really
and now the idea 96 to see form getting
a five and e 50 yeah if I was still gone
check black forfeits on time yeah I
think this was awesome decent game maybe
it's a hard to tell in blitz at this
kind of this kind of endgame I like for
white I now threaten or threatening
Rupert e7 so i'm not sure that he has
something else really then this move and
well how to turn maybe this was this was
okay the apron might be even more
dangerous he is just in time with his
King to stuff our corn he's got this
check to him to help them I don't think
that black should lose this year maybe
f5 or something high five yeah laughter
at five I simply cannot enter with the
king so nice
nice I overlooked a cool move here I
need to show this right need to show
this yeah oops I thought this was too
much claw so let's just go back here
here I could play c7 Kingda 786 shame a
shame I didn't have enough time to
actually find this very nice very nice
move the ideas if black takes here on
white wins instantly right you need to
go here b7 and then one of those pawns
so yeah just the home run so cannot take
on f5 and okay this is just our same
basically so black cannot take one of
those and yeah I'm threatening to take
only six if he takes here and this is
possible and black cannot keep the
bishop if he goes here I'll play this
and it's over he needs to take the take
and now this position I've I'm a part of
a piece up here um yeah it should be
winning really be here it's a bit tricky
so and then this list and blitz right
like has those pawns to push but this is
a very nice idea very nice idea you
should have play two player 5 himself
here this move to oops couldn't take
good move here um this move to to to
close up the Kings side but he went went
king d 7 and then I had he went here and
now I had this f5 idea I mean this one
very cute yeah okay thanks for watching
cool cool endgame motif here too
to remember to break through okay thanks
for watching and talk to you soon in a
new video